what is photosynthesis
and why is it hard well there are
different
forms
i mean basically you're taking hydrogen
and you're sticking it onto co2 and it's
powered by the sun the question is where
are you taking the hydrogen from
and in photosynthesis that we know in
plants it's coming from water so you're
using the power of the sun to split
water take out the hydrogen stick it
onto co2 and the oxygen is a waste
product and you just throw it out throw
it away so it's a you know the single
greatest planetary pollution event in
the whole history of
of the earth the pollutant being oxygen
yes
yeah it also made possible animals you
can't have large active animals without
an oxygenated atmosphere at least not
not in the sense that we know on earth
so that's a really big invention in this
huge intervention yes and it happened
once there's a few things that happen
once on earth and you know you're always
stuck with this problem is it once it
happened did it become so good so
quickly that it precluded the the same
thing happening ever again
or are there other reasons and we really
have to look at each one in turn and
think
what's
why does it only happen once in this
case
it's really difficult
to split water it requires a lot of
power and that power you're effectively
separating charge across a membrane and
the way in which you do it if it doesn't
all rush back and and kind of cause an
explosion right at the site requires
really careful wiring um and that wiring
it can't be easy to get it right because
you know
the plants that we see around us they
have chloroplasts those chloroplasts
with cyanobacterial ones those
cyanobacteria are the only group of
bacteria that can do that type of
photosynthesis so there's plenty of
opportunity there's not even many
bacteria so who who invented
photosynthesis that the cyanobacteria or
their ancestors and there's not many um
no other bacteria can do what's called
oxygenic photosynthesis lots of other
bacteria can split i mean you can take
your your hydrogen from somewhere else
you can take it from hydrogen sulfide
bubbling out of a hydrothermal vent grab
your two hydrogens the sulfur is the
waste now
um you can do it from iron you can take
electrons so the early oceans were
probably full of iron you can take an
electron from ferrous ion so iron two
plus and make it iron three plus which
now precipitates as rust
uh and you take a a proton from the
acidic early ocean stick it there now
you've got a hydrogen atom stick it onto
co2 you've just done the trick the
trouble is
you bury yourself in rusty iron and with
sulfur you can bury yourself in sulfur
one of the reasons oxygenic
photosynthesis is so much better is the
waste product is oxygen which just
bubbles away
that seems like extremely unlikely
and it's extremely essential for the
evolution of complex organisms
because of all the oxygen
yeah and that didn't accumulate quickly
either
so it's converting
what is it it's converting energy from
the sun
and the resource of water
into
the resource needed for animals
both resources needed for animals we
need to eat and we need to burn the food
and the we're eating plants um which are
getting their energy from the sun and
we're burning it with their waste
products which is the oxygen
so there's a lot of kind of circularity
in that but with with without an
oxygenated planet you couldn't really
have
um
predation
you
you don't you you can have animals but
you can't really have animals that go
around and eat each other you can't have
ecosystems as we know them
you